Hi, everyone. This is the
question review
for PD and AD.
So we have a 7-year
-old male started on
medication after
presenting with episodes of
rigidity and slowed
movements. The drug he
was administered is
also known to treat
viral infections. Which
of the following does
this describe? So
looking at the choices,
we do have all medications
used for PD, which
is the likely diagnosis
of this patient.
But what we are told
is that this drug
also manages a virus.
And we know that there
was a medication
in the lecture that
is used to treat
influenza A because it
will block the uncoding
of the M2 channel.
In that channel, you
needed acid fritication
to happen. You
need hydrogen ions
in to allow for the
release of the RNA.
And that was known
as amantadine.
So looking at
the choices, we
know this is
the best choice.
Amantadine also
blocks the NMDA
receptor. It blocks
muscarinic receptors,
but for PD, it
increases dopamine.
Apomorphine is used for
the freezing episodes.
That is considered to
be the off phenomena.
and this drug can in
fact be a dopamine
agonist but it can cause
a severe nausea and
vomiting which
is managed with
trimethobenzamide. Not a
serotonin blocker because
that can actually
decrease the blood
pressure of the patient
rather significantly.
Benztripine is the
muscarinic blocker and
muscarinic blockers
will help with the
tremors because of that
loss of dopamine and
there's a higher level
of acetylcholine.
Anticapone is the COMT
inhibitor and this
is the one that only
works in the periphery.
Tolicapone works both
in periphery and in
the CNS but tolicapone
is more hepatotoxic.
Levodopa and carbidopa
are the drugs that
are used basically
first line for PD.
Carbidopa has no
effect on the disease,
but it inhibits the
decarboxylase so that
more L-dopa can get
through the periphery
into the CNS and be
converted to dopamine.
And then pramipexol
is the one that
has dopamine
agonist potential.
It has a D3, So
this one would be
associated with more
of the behavioral
effects like
the compulsion.
So here, A is the best
answer. That
is amantadine.
And the other effect
of amantadine is
the levito
-verticularis, where the
possibility of this
adverse effect is
because of
vasoconstriction and a
decrease in blood
flow, which may be due
to the blockade of
the NMDA receptor.
A 66-year-old male was
started on additional
medication to manage
worsening PD. he was
administered a drug
which mimics a specific
antidepressant in
mechanism without the
avoidance of certain foods.
Which of the following
describes the mechanism
of this drug? So
we want to say here
that we're talking about
tyramine because I
did say that there is
a group of antidepressants
although they're
not widely used anymore.
They're not given
because of the adverse
effect with foods that
that buildup of
tyramine in the synaptic
cleft will actually
cause a displacement of
norepinephrine in
circulation and that would
cause the hypertensive
crisis and that's
going to be true of mal
-a inhibitors but the
one that we want to
discuss in this lecture
is the one that is
specific for enhancing the
dopamine in the cns
and we know that those
are considered to be
MALB inhibitors and
that's something like
sefinamide, selegiline,
risagiline.
They don't carry
this food drug
interaction.
Inhibitor of COMPT is
going to be entacopone
and tolicopone.
Agonist of D2 can be
rapinerol. It could be
even bromocriptine but
But bromocryptine
is not used much for
PD. It's used for high
levels of prolactin.
Conversion of
dopamine in the CNS.
That's going to
be what I would
describe as the
mechanism of levodopa.
Remember, dopamine
cannot be given
because it would
not cross the
blood-brain
barrier on its own.
And then blockade
of the muscarinic
receptor that
we can use for
tremors. that's
going to be something
like benstrapine
or trihexafenadil.
So A is, in fact,
the best answer.
And as you can
see, with MAO-B
inhibitors, they're
going to work centrally.
So dopamine is
not going to be
converted to its
metabolite, DOPAC.
A 75-year-old female
with a five-year
history of Parkinson's
presented with
worsening tremors.
She was started on
benchtropine. Which
of the following
adverse effects should
she be warned of?
Okay,
so benchtropine, if
you're looking at
what I have here
about the mechanism,
benchtropine,
looking at the name
like atropine,
is going to be a
muscarinic blocker.
So the adverse
effects would be
dry as a bone,
and heart runs alone,
and mad as a hatter,
and red as a beet,
and the eyes. thinking
about turning on sympathetics
with a muscarinic
blocker you would
probably get a dilated
pupil which is known
as medriasis the pupils
are wide so looking here
is it bronchoconstriction
no if anything
muscarinic blockers
would dilate going
back to the lecture the
drugs that increase
acetylcholine might
cause bronchoconstriction
and bronchospasm and
that could be something
like rivastigmine.
Low heart rate,
that too would be
something like an
acetylcholine esterase
inhibitor, like we
discussed for AD.
Bradycardia tends to
be common in patients
taking those drugs.
If anything, benzopine
would increase the
action in the AV and SA
node, so the heart rate
would be more rapid.
Small pupils, that is
going to be meiosis,
and that's again
parasympathetic. So
parasympathetic, I
would be thinking about
something like an
acetylcholine esterase
inhibitor. Here, it
would be more mediasis.
Constipation, well,
that would be the best
choice because
lacrimation would not be
the case. If anything,
the patient would
complain that their eyes
are dry, their mouth
is dry with something
like bantropine. Okay,
so this question is
really reviewing for
you the adverse effects
of drugs that work
parasympathetically
and those that work
sympathetically. And
remember, muscarinic
block means you're
turning on sympathetics.
Muscarinic agonism
means you're
more in the
parasympathetic
rest and digest
part of the CNS.
So again, the balance
between dopamine
and acetylcholine is
going to be affected.
And as I said, with
elderly, when it
comes to muscarinic
blockade, we worry
about cognition. So they
should be discouraged
from taking this
for a long period
of time. And when
you do give the
medication, give the
lowest dose possible.
So these receptors, along
with alpha, serotonin 2A,
histamine 1, they're
going to be GQ.
So you're increasing
phospholipase C,
that's going to
increase IP3 and DAG,
and that's going
to shuttle in the
stored and free
calcium into the cell.
A 25-year-old male
was recently diagnosed
with psychosis.
His paranoia and
hallucinations continued
and he was started
on medication to
manage these episodes.
On follow-up, he reported
having difficulty
moving and he had
tremors. Which of the
following was the cause
of this presentation?
So if anything, if
we're thinking about
what he came in with,
he was having some
type of psychotic
episode. and the
hallucinations and the
delusions and paranoia
really show that. So
he's probably getting an
increase in action in
the mesolimbic area.
So he probably was
given some type of drug
for acute psychosis,
like a D2 blocker.
And with that blockade,
the mesolimbic
area helped the episode.
But blocking in the
nigrostriadium was
the reason why he
started having tremors
and the bradykinesia.
So looking at the
choices, bromocryptine,
if anything, bromocryptine
would in fact
be the opposite. It's
a dopamine agonist
and that would help
with some of the
movement difficulties
and it would actually
complicate the
psychosis. But again,
bromocryptine, we use
it more for high levels
of prolactin because
it has an ergotamine
in its structure
and ergotamine can
cause more vasoconstriction
and vasospasm.
Carbidopa and
levodopa, again, may
cause changes in
mood, but if you're
talking about
difficulty moving, it
would not cause that.
In fact, this one
is the first line
for treating PD.
And then haloperidol,
as you can
see, is probably the
best answer. This
is the two
blocker, and I will
embellish on this
concept when we get
to psychosis later
in the semester.
Ropinerol is considered
to be another
drug that we know as
a dopamine agonist.
so if anything it may
cause this presentation
and if anything it
would resolve the
movement issue and
then tolicapone again
this is the one that
stops the breakdown
of levodopa both in
the periphery and
in the cns so again
you're going to get
an increase ultimately
of the dopamine
tolicopone is the one
if we wanted to say
how is it different
than entacopone well
it works in both
places both in the cns
and the periphery
but tolicopone does
carry the liability of
increased hepatotoxicity
so even though
entacopone is only
working at the periphery
comped enzyme it's
not going to be as
toxic to the liver.
So haloperidol here is
in fact the best answer.
Okay, and I said
the same thing about
antiemetics because
there's a D2
receptor in the
chemo trigger zone.
If that is agonized,
it's going to make
the patient more nauseous
and more prone to
vomiting. And then the
VMAT inhibitors will
deplete monoamines,
and that is used for
patients that have
Huntington's disease.
But again, the
effects of that
medication, too,
will follow the same
symptoms of
Parkinson's disease.
An 84-year-old
female was brought to
her physician by
her family with a
reported two-year
decline in cognition.
She does not recognize
anyone and is
unable to do simple
tasks on her own.
Physician decided
on a drug which
would block a
receptor for an
excitatory
neurotransmitter. Which of
the following does
this describe?
So looking at the
choices, you can see
that A, C, D, and E
are probably the ones
that we want to consider
for this patient
that has a change in
the cognition. Okay.
Aestradephalene,
as I talked about,
this is the one that
we would be most likely
wanting to give in
patients that have,
um, PD and they have
the freezing episode
because it is an
adenosine blocker and it's
going to restore the
balance of, of GABA in
the striadium and the
globus, uh, pallidus.
When the dopaminergic
neurons are lost, this
pathway becomes more
overactive and that's
going to enhance more
GABA which can have
a negative effect on
the motor function.
So istrodefilin is
going to block those
adenosine receptors. So
this is not the correct
answer. I I mentioned
that it resembles
theophylline, and
theophylline's structure is
like caffeine. So
that's why some of the
insomnia and the weight
loss that you saw with
this medication may
be due to the fact
that the patient does
have some stimulation.
Donepazil and
rivastigmine, if you
recall, those are the
anticholinesterase
inhibitors. So by
blocking the enzyme,
they're increasing
more acetylcholine,
and with those
two, that would
help to improve
cognition in some way.
With rivastigmine,
this was the one that
would also inhibit
butyrocholinesterase.
Galantamine will
agonize the nicotinic
receptors, and that
increases the acetylcholine
in the synaptic cleft.
So these two could
be used for cognition,
but they are mainly
for anticholin esterase.
So is tachrine, but
tachrine was the first
one developed. This
one had more of the
muscarinic agonist
effects. So patients were
more prone to get the
salivation and the
GI upset and probably
bradycardia more with
tachrine than some of
the later acetylcholin
esterase inhibitors.
So memantine is the
best choice, and
I mentioned
that this is an
uncompetitive antagonist.
So in the area
where there's the
NMDA receptor for
glutamate, this
drug binds close by.
And with that,
you're preserving the
glutamate that you
need for your regular
function, and
you do need some
glutamate, but binding
there uncompetitively
would mean that
you're decreasing
your overactive
amounts of glutamate.
And that would be
the best answer here.
And this one is used
for more of the patients
that have the
moderate to severe AD.
So C would be the best
answer for this question.
This is just
reviewing that the
main mechanisms
for AD are going
to be cholinesterase
inhibitors.
We're going to
have memantine
for more moderate
to severe.
And then lastly, when
patients are in the
early stages of Alzheimer's,
they can use the
monoclonals. And
remember, those are going
to have an effect on
decreasing amyloid B
that is making those
plaques that are going to
ultimately, uh, result
in, in neuronal loss.
But I said that those
need to be started
very early. You also
have to do thorough
testing, which can involve
a CSF, um, draw. It
could involve the PET
scan. And once you start
taking a drug like
lecanumab, I did mention
that doing MRIs to
look for any edema and
hemorrhages is going
to be very important.
Okay,
so that's it for
now. If there are
any questions,
please let me know.
Until then, have a great
day and I'll
see you soon.